sentez Canada comme la santé publique
confirme que notre roue est potable la
mairesse de saguenis est montrée
insistante même si elle contient jusqu'à
4 fois plus de composés perfluorés que
la limite recommandée par Santé Canada
l'eau de la baie demeure propre à la
consommation c'est pourquoi les 8000
résidents touchés n'ont pas été avisés
plutôt par la ville qui connaissait le
problème depuis la mi-avril dans le cas
ici qui nous préoccupe qu'il n'y a pas
de notion d'urgence la source du
problème de la mousse ignifuge utilisée
sur un ancien site d'entraînement de
pompiers à la base militaire de
Bagotville pour éteindre des incendies
carburants le ministère de la Défense
nationale assume sa part de
responsabilité en présume que la
présence des puissent sur la propriété
est liée à l'utilisation passer de
mousse extinctrice pour l'entraînement
et les opérations de 1972 au début des
années 2010 la mousse a été utilisée par
la MDN pour l'entraînement des pompiers
que bon voisin nous nous engageons à
gérer de manière responsable les effets
de nos opérations antérieures même si la
ville assure que l'eau de la bille reste
potable elle compte tout de même
abaisser la concentration de pfas sous
la barre des 30 nanogrammes par litre
comme le recommande Santé Canada d'ici
janvier 2024 des travaux pour filtrer
l'eau à la sortie des deux pluies
contaminés et pour brancher les puits
privés au réseau d'aqueduc municipal
seront effectués des recherches seront
aussi entamées pour trouver une nouvelle
source d'eau potable on veut offrir un
autre moyen un système qui est beaucoup
plus permanent donc de vérifier si ça va
pas une source ou même plusieurs autres
sources d'eau potable qui pourraient
alimenter les 8000 les 8000 personnes
les 3000 quelques habitations touchées
dans le secteur de la baie les 8000
citoyens touchés seront invisibles par
courrier d'ici la fin de la semaine un
site internet a aussi été mis sur pied
par Saguenay pour répondre à leurs
questions mes inquiétudes par rapport à
ça sont
mignonnes mais chez pour les gens qui
doivent rester plus près ça doit être
inquiétant t'inquiétant
c'est trop pollué
de couleur je fais bouillir mon eau
souvent mais c'est surtout pour les
biberons du bébé le montant des travaux
projetés à la baie est évalué à 6
millions de dollars quant à savoir qui
paiera la facture la ville assure être
en pour parler avec le gouvernement
fédéral ici Jean-François Coulomb
Radio-Canada Saguenay